Our entire medical system
really relies on antibiotics.
This would be the biggest
health crisis
that we've experienced this century.
We don't hear about it.
But it's already here.
Nobody is safe, until we're all safe.
What would a world without
antibiotics look like?
Well, I think it would look
a lot like the past,
where a lot of people
would die younger than they do now.
Just think about war -
more people died of infections
and their wounds,
than died actually
on the battlefield.
The discovery of various classes
of antibiotics in the 20th Century
had a profound impact on health care.
So treatment of infection suddenly
became very straightforward,
and it's something
that we benefit a lot from today.
Antibiotics protect people
during operative surgery -
Caesarean sections, replacement
joints, let alone cancer treatments.
Antibiotics added, on average,
20 years life to everyone.
We went to the hospital,
the emergency room.
They said they gave him
a broad spectrum antibiotic.
And then they took me
to another room and they're like,
"Your son has an infection.
We don't know the source."
We were in the ICU
with like 10 doctors,
and they said he wasn't
really going to make it.
At that point, I knew
that he was dead.
I could feel it.
And that's when we learned
that Simon had contracted
an antibiotic resistant bacterium,
a superbug.
And I had never heard
of any of this.
Alexander Fleming's discovery
of penicillin was immense.
Noticing that in a petri dish
where bacteria were growing,
there were white areas where
the bacteria were not growing.
And he realised that
something had happened.
He looked and found
the fungus, penicillin -
our first effective antibiotic
that saved masses of lives.
Most antibiotics come
from soil and fungi.
When I expose bacteria
to antibiotics,
they're going to become resistant,
which is very bad because
we haven't discovered
a new antibiotic
in the last 30 years.
Growing up back in Mexico,
you didn't need a prescription
to get an antibiotic.
You had a little bit
of a sore throat,
you go to the pharmacy
and get an antibiotic.
And that only gives more and more
chances to these bugs
to acquire mutations
to become resistant.
The situation today is more
serious than people realise.
It's actually the first real study
looking at all the data -
494 million patient records -
to model what is happening.
It is predicted that by 2050,
10 million people
are going to die every year
from complications with superbugs
or resistant microbes.
So we really have
to find alternative strategies
to fight against these bugs.
A world without antibiotics -
I sometimes call it
"the post-antibiotic apocalypse" -
would impact on our food chain too,
because animals would get ill,
plants would get ill and die.
We would really
be in the most dreadful mess.
As an individual, I think
one of the most important things
is don't ask for antibiotics
if they are not offered to you.
If you are prescribed antibiotics,
then make sure you finish the course
of antibiotics that you're given.
Because if you don't
finish the course,
even if you're feeling better,
there might be some
residual infection
that could become resistant.
We have probably found
the easy-to-find antibiotics.
But that doesn't mean there
are not many more to be found.
If we keep recycling
the same old treatments,
then the problem is just
going to exacerbate.
One of the main bottlenecks
with antibiotic research
is that the easiest thing to do
is to look at the structures
of existing antibiotics,
and modify those slightly
to try to overcome the resistance.
It's much more challenging to find a
completely new class of antibiotics.
So we have to fund quite widely
in order to be able to identify
those strategies
that are going to work best.
I think if there were more awareness
then there would be more
general pressure from society
on governments and on companies
to fund more research
into targeting this problem.
We should be anticipating problems,
and doing something about them
before they become
enormous global crises.